is
will morrissey holds the william and
patricia lamothe chair
and united states constitution at
hillsdale college where he has taught
since 2000.
dr morrissey is the author of eight
books on statesmanship and political
philosophy
his most recent book the dilemma of
progressivism how roosevelt taft and
wilson reshaped the american regime of
self-government
is the companion volume to his previous
book on self government
self-government the american theme
presidents of the founding and civil war
he received his ba summa [ __ ] laude from
kenyon college and his m.a
and ph.d from the new school for social
research
he has written for the new york times
the washington times and the american
political science review
among many other publications today he
will be speaking on the timely topic
what would abraham lincoln do
constitutional crisis and the challenge
of self-government
please join me in welcoming dr will
morrissey
thank you tiffany and thank you david
for inviting me here today
if abraham lincoln were alive today
the first thing he'd say to us is you
think you've got troubles
americans today regret the sharpness of
our political divisions
150 years ago today abraham lincoln
addressed
his fellow citizens in his first
inaugural address
that phrase fellow citizens tended to
the optimistic
side given the proclaimed secession of
seven
states from the union before doing
anything
lincoln had a few things to say before
saying anything
he formed some thoughts a wise procedure
which ought to serve as an example for
all of us more of the time
he began by telling his audience that in
giving his inaugural address he complied
with a custom
as old as the government itself he
concluded
famously with an appeal to the better
angels of our
nature his argument moves exactly
that way from custom to nature
the link between custom and nature is
reason i said he made an argument
it's a logical argument not merely an
appeal to passions
nor nor is it a set of sound bites
as an experienced lawyer he expected the
jury of his fellow citizens to
understand a clear chain
of thought governed by the principle of
non-contradiction
if he were alive today he might attempt
the same thing
and many of his listeners would find it
refreshing
or at least novel others might find it
confusing
but they could get used to it in
complying with custom
with human convention lincoln affirmed
his law-abidingness
his respect for infidelity to the
agreements men and women make with each
other
especially in so far as they are fellow
citizens
he assured southerners and northerners
that he would abide
by his party's political platform
another agreement among citizens
which had first affirmed the rights of
states to permit slavery
within their confines and second which
had supported the fugitive slave
law part of that larger law or
convention the united states
constitution at that time
he argued that such conventions must
remain in force
until altered or abolished by the rulers
of the united states
namely the sovereign people speaking in
a constitutional majority
that went for him as president it also
went for the south
as the duly elected constitutional
executive of the united states he
intended to hold them
to that secession from a constitutional
union without the consent of the other
parties
to that convention is he said the
essence
of anarchy after appealing to the rule
of
law to constitutional legitimacy the
highest custom
lincoln then observed a limitation of
law
if one part of the union believes
slavery is right
it will obey the law suppressing the
foreign slave trade
with very little alacrity if another
part of the union believes slavery is
wrong
it will obey the fugitive slave law with
equally little
alacrity secession would make
each of these laws not merely difficult
to enforce
but void in half of the former union
but these two new countries could not
separate
physically why then he asked would
treaties
between these countries respecting slave
trade
or fugitive slaves prove more effective
than those laws within the union is
union therefore not
antecedent to law
lincoln continued offering a new
constitutional convention
invoking prudence patriotism
christianity
god himself the creator of the nature
which appears for the first time as the
last word
of his plea to the jury of his fellow
citizens
flexible with respect to convention
which fellow citizens can
change lincoln concludes this invocation
of nature and of nature's god
beings of endurance and of permanence
respectively
beings that set the standard for human
conventions our laws of nature are the
laws of nature
and of nature's god not antecedent to
the union
that is antecedent to the laws
after all americans had seceded in 1776
unilaterally from the political bans or
conventions with the british empire
the result of that c-session had not
been anarchy but the very constitutional
union now threatened by this attempted
secession
what's the difference the difference was
that the secession of 1776 had been
founded upon the truth of natural right
understood as the god-given equal claim
to each
of each hume individual human being to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
the secessionists of 1861 by contrast
founded their claim to secession either
upon a non-natural ancestral right to
liberty
a liberty from which those who those who
shared
none of the citizens ancestry could
therefore be
excluded right or they founded it upon
the flat claim that nature itself had
denied
the capacity for self-government the
full exercise of economic and political
liberty
to one or more races within the united
states while granting that capacity to
another race
rightfully the master of the others
from this disagreement upon the moral of
moral principle of natural right flowed
two
opposing political differences
the slave-holding states disagreed with
the free states concerning
their regime the slave-holding statesman
also disagreed with the
non-slave-holding statesman concerning
the character of the american
polity regime and polity two two uh
items that are on that uh
list that that i've given you that piece
of paper and i'll just run through it
very quickly
by regime i mean what aristotle meant in
describing political rule in human
societies
a regime consists of three distinct but
closely related elements
first the persons who rule are they one
few or many are they good or bad are
there
are they a good or bad character second
the second dimension of regimes the
institutions by which rulers rule
this is the structure or the form of the
regime
if the people are sovereign they will
likely
generate institutions that enable them
to exercise their rule
congress for their representatives for
example
if it's a monarchy the czar of course
will have his secret police
so the institutions are likely to back
up
the ruling the the ruling dimension of
the regime or should i say the persons
who are ruling within any regime
the third dimension of a regime is the
way of life
that's shared by the citizens of the
regime are they warriors or merchants
are they hunters or farmers fathers and
mothers or
moms and dads that's the that's the
regime
to understand politics clearly orient
yourselves toward that and you can't go
too far wrong
and i've i say this for many years of
experience thinking about these things
and listening to other people give their
thoughts on them by polity that's a word
i just
assigned to something that is a another
phenomenon
that's important to keep track of and
that's the the
the conjunction of size and degree of
centralization within a political
community
size and degree of centralization uh by
that i mean i'll give you an ex
examples in the ancient world uh apollos
sometimes called a city-state was small
but
centralized wasn't it because everyone
who was a ruler in apollos
even it was the many who ruled you could
get them all in one place so that they
could deliberate amongst themselves at
one time
that's a that's a small but centralized
entity
the ancient world also had those big
sprawling empires places like persia for
example
where they were big but they were
decentralized
uh the the various provinces typically
had a fairly significant degree of
self-government for day-to-day affairs
in
an ancient empire later on you had a few
a couple more uh entities cropping up
feudalism feudal societies where you
have basically
concentrations of authority a king a set
of aristocrats
the institutions of a church law courts
and so forth
each with their own independent source
of revenue several of them with their
own source
independent source of military right and
this would be
these these sources of authority would
circulate in a kind of colloidal
suspension or a kind of equilibrium
right
this was replaced by a fairly large
entity but decentralized in other words
the thing that replaced that of course
was the modern state
machiavelli's invention strongly
centralized large but strongly
centralized a powerhouse that could
defeat
a feudal a feudal society certainly
apollos
and could probably knock off an ancient
empire unless it got its act together
or you could have a third possibility
another possibility
which would be the united states
a state all right you know recognizably
a modern state
but a confederal state what publius
calls a compound
republic that is a state in which the
central government has its own
independently funded sources of
authority
and whose laws are the supreme law of
the land
but within that confederation the states
have their own independently funded
sources of authority
and their laws are supreme within their
own borders
now there's a link in the united states
regime between
the regime proper and the polity or the
between republicanism and confederalism
and that is an article for section four
in which it says the united states shall
guarantee
to every state in this union a
republican
form of government that is the
confederal structure of the american
polity
shall reinforce the republican character
of
all the american regimes
slavery presented a problem here
in the 1790s james madison framer of the
constitution
congressman future president slave
holder but also
opponent of slavery wrote himself a note
which for obvious purposes never saw a
publication until the 20th century
quote in proportion of slavery prevails
in a state
the government however democratic in
name
must be aristocratic in fact
the power lies in a part instead of the
whole
in the hands of property not of numbers
all the ancient
popular governments were for this reason
aristocracies
the majority were slaves he continued
the southern states of america are on
the same principle
aristocracies in his own virginia he
estimated slaves and non-freeholding
whites amounted to nearly three-fourths
of the population
how then shall the federal government
enforce
the republican guarantee clause
it's a time bomb in the constitution
essentially
in his recent book mastering america the
historian robert bonner shows how
southern statesmen initially centered
their political strategy on defending
slave-holding oligarchic regimes by
means of
the confederal polity established by the
founders
senator john c calhoun epitomized these
statesmen
so long as the structure of the union
provided a protective
shield for slave holders from foreign
regimes that discount against
slavery most notably of course the
british empire right
calhoun upheld nationalism playing the
war hawk in 1812 for example
in this he followed his fellow south
carolinian charles pinckney
who told the state's ratifying
convention back in 1788
that only a quixote would suppose that a
state with a dense slave population
could long maintain her independence if
she stood alone
or was only connected with the southern
states but by the late 1820s
as the slave states prospered within the
union calhoun could begin of thinking of
just
such independence as is well known by
the end of his life he could set the
price of the continuation of the unified
confederal
polity at the level of his concurrent
majority notion
complete with a dual presidency from one
from the north one from the south
throughout the 1850s both southern
secessionists
and southern union unionists disagreed
not only
not over slavery but over which policy
better defended
slavery by 1861 the confederate states
of america president jefferson davis
lamented
quote the evil hour in which some of our
most distinguished southern statesman
he would have thought of jefferson
madison who admitted that slavery was an
evil
an admission that took from us all
ground saved that of necessity
the sort of argument that thomas
jefferson made we've got the wolf by the
ears we can't let him go on the contrary
davis and the secessionists contended
that slavery formed an indispensable
foundation for
their new regime when in desperation
near the end of the war davis
proposed to arm the remaining slaves in
exchange for a promise of emancipation
the virginia newspaper editor george
bagby replied and this is one of the
quotes that bonner has
unearthed a surrender of slavery is a
surrender of everything it is a
subjugation
by the yankee idea subjugated by the
yankee idea we become yankees
if we are yankees why not be in the same
in the same union with the rest of the
yankees
some southerners were just as logical as
lincoln in other words
indeed in 1854 in jackson michigan not
far from where hillsdale college is
located
the republicans named their party the
republican party precisely in order
quote to battle for the first principles
of
republican government and against the
schemes of aristocracy
the most revolting and oppressive the
earth has ever been
cursed with so right out of the
republican
uh statement of 1840 54.
despite his recourse to reason and its
pa
and to patriotic sentiment lincoln's
argument in the first inaugural address
failed to persuade the union's regime
enemies
he failed to persuade the secessionists
because they no longer wanted
and no longer believed that they needed
the regime or the polity of the american
founders the regime and polity lincoln
considered himself morally and legally
bound to defend
i need not detain you with an account of
what lincoln did about that except to
observe that the conduct of the war in
its endgame
staged by his generals aimed at breaking
the slave plantation aristocrats
and forcing them to earn a living with
their own hands
reportedly when asked how the plantation
owners would survive without their
slaves
and how the slaves would survive without
their plantation owners
he replied partly root hog
or die hollywood captured this moment
when scarlett o'hara found
herself unearthing a turnip
and vowing never to go hungry again
being scarlet and having the
anti-secessionist
rhett butler in her thrall she didn't
i have detained you with an account of
regimes
and of politics because it frames an
answer to the question what would
lincoln do if he returned to us today
to provide an answer to the question
just framed
we should i want to stipulate two
additional points
first we should assume that lincoln
returns to us fully aware
of american and indeed of world history
in the seventh score and ten years
that now separate his first inaugural
address from us
this eliminates the need for him to
yokel around for a while
gaping at our airplanes and our cell
phones and reading up on 20th century
history he's been watching us
all this time second and following from
that first point we must measure the
distance
in the political circumstances between
his time and ours
the regime of republicanism and the
polity of confederalism remain
front and center for us as they were for
him but in a radically different way
it would be nice if you could use
lincoln or the founders as a kind
as computers you could print out uh
answers to the questions that we fed to
them
that won't happen right we can't do that
the international slave trade for
example remains with us and of course
lincoln would
oppose it but in as much as legal
slavery has now disappeared from the
united states where would lincoln find
the threat of oligarchy today
america now features several uh
oligarchic
structures uh business corporations
which are private bureaucracies
professional organizations that require
certification for entry into the
marketplace
which would be semi-public bureaucracies
and of course the administrative
apparatus of the modern
state public bureaucracies left on their
own
private and semi-private bureaucracies
will tend to rise and fall depending on
whether their services meet some
felt need of their fellow citizens and
in the case the corporations of buyers
and sellers around the world
such bureaucracies usually fall under
the constitution's interstate commerce
clause
congress may regulate them wisely or
foolishly
congressmen may or may not accept bribes
legal or illegal from them
but by themselves they pose no threat to
the regime of republicanism
public bureaucracy is another matter
tenured public administ
administrators or bureaucrats derive
their claim to rule
not from birth or from elections
but from expertise it's a quasi-aristic
claim we rightly rule because we possess
scientific knowledge of that realm of
human activity
our agency for overseas finance
education war family life
business international relations
medicine
agriculture transportation the list is
long
i won't continue it moreover we also
possess the science of administration
itself whereby we can rule these
activities with more efficiency
and less prejudice or personal interest
than anyone
else by regulating private and
semi-public bureaucracies along with the
daily activities of civil associations
families and individuals public
bureaucracies decisively centralize the
american
polity making it less confederal
they also transform the american regime
following at madison we can say that
insofar as
bureaucracy prevails in a state the
government however democratic in name
must be
aristocratic in fact but here is a
crucial distinction
unlike slave holders bureaucrats are not
confined to one part of the country
the new aristocracy has been marbled
through
all regions of our country from
washington dc to wasilla
alaska lincoln confronted a
semi-aristocratic regime
limited to a geographic section but
but this this brought the danger of
civil war but it also held out the
prospect the regime might be contained
or failing that and in response to
rebellion conquered and reconstructed
subject to regime change in other words
but today's nationwide bureaucratic
oligarchy pervades
all sections all climates all
populations of america
not disunion but what the federal
what the founders called statist
consolidation
right statist consolidation now
threatens what would lincoln
say to that well begin with the fact
that lincoln was a confirmed liberal in
the sense that word had in the 18th and
19th centuries
with locke liberalism regards labor as
prior to
capital having worked as a ferryman on a
river
flat boat lincoln regarded the right to
earn your living by your own efforts and
to keep what you've earned as a
fundamental element of human flourishing
one that he shared with the haughtiest
crown head of europe
and equally as he explained to stephen
douglas in one of their debates
with an african-american woman living in
slavery
my understanding of the hired laborer is
this he said
a young man finds himself of an age to
be dismissed from parental
control moved out of the basement
he didn't say that i did he has for his
capital
nothing but two strong hands that god
has given him
a heart willing to labor and a freedom
to choose the mode of his work in the
manner of his employment
he finds an employer and works for him
in terms according with their mutual
consent
with time and effort he will accumulate
surplus capital
raise a family and do was what he was
done by
for some unemployed youth of the next
generation
quote this is the progress that human
nature
is entitled to the pursuit of happiness
the great principle for which this
government was really formed
only human beings invest and discover
exercise reason the self-governing
faculty
only they improve their workmanship
while they labor
according accordingly the 1860
republican platform upon which lincoln
stood said this
the people justly view with alarm
the reckless extravagance which pervades
every department of the federal
government
a return to rigid econ economy and
accountability is indispensable
to arrest the systematic plunder of the
public treasury by
favored partisans while this recent
startling developments of frauds
and corruptions at the federal
metropolis show that an
entire change of administration is
imperatively
demanded
so i think it's safe to say that lincoln
would like to see a reduction of
government expenditures
right at the same time we shouldn't
forget that
lincoln's republican party combined the
economic policies of the two predecessor
parties the whig
party and the free soil parties the
whigs i'll start with the whigs
they weren't libertarians in our sense
of the word in propounding his american
system senator henry clay
the man who lincoln famously called my
beau edial
of a statesman uh he probably said
bullied ideal he was a real american not
like me you know
uh college professor and he right
he the clay endorsed endorsed public
works as had the federalists and some
democrats like james madison
but these there's a distinction these
statesmen did not endorse
public works in order to directly
stimulate employment as the new
dealers and the social democrats
generally do
the canals highways river and harbor
improvements and other enterprise
they endorsed were intended to stimulate
commerce to extend
the network extend the network of free
of the free market across the country
to enhance the founders regime of
commercial commercial republicanism
in establishing the interstate highway
system after world war ii
uh president eisenhower exhibited strong
wiggish tendencies you might say
um if i have a chance in the in the in
the question and answer period i'll tell
you what my father did about the
extension of the highway system in new
jersey in 1920
but i'll get back to that today lincoln
might well endorse what we now call
infrastructure spending as long as it
reinforced interstate commerce did not
serve a merely local
intra state purpose and didn't amount to
a make work program
jobs should come primarily from the
commerce thus assisted not
so much from the projects themselves
that is such internal improvements will
deploy the central government to make
civil social institutions
stronger rather than to take them over
or to dominate them by regulation
lincoln it should be added disagreed
with his platform's call for a railroad
to the pacific ocean
on the grounds that it would cost too
much
given today's budget deficit therefore
he might frown upon
federal expenditures on high-speed
trains
now the free soil side getting to the
free soil side of republicanism
that more clearly addresses the need
directly to reduce
statism or central government rule over
civil society
americans had settled on i had settled
on public lands of course and the
republican party platform endorsed
the what it called free homestead policy
meaning if you had already worked on
that land you'd settled it you'd chop
down those trees and
built a farm then you would have first
rights to
acquiring the land with which you had
mixed your labor in that lock-in way
right again the first principle of
economic liberalism is to secure the
natural right to keep what you have
earned
given the enormous resources now owned
by the united states government some 233
billion dollars of non-military property
plants equipment
and given also the astonishing level of
federal indebtedness
lincoln might very well try to devise
ways of as we now say privatizing many
of these assets
seeing people could purchase more things
that they would then have the right to
keep
indeed he might consider experimenting
with the privatization of that wiggish
interstate highway system that has begun
to crumble
under interstate hands as for the
bureaucracy itself the americans of the
19th century lincoln very much included
saw no need for a bureaucracy of any
substantial size public administration
of the united in the in america of
madison clay
calhoun and lincoln fell to the
political parties
and not to licensed professional experts
this meant that public administration
was highly responsive
to political events most particularly
elections
a change of presidential administrations
really meant
a change in administration a
federal government was re-staffed with
persons committed to the party platform
of the president
controlled financially by a congress
that was equally partisan
today lincoln would quite likely look to
expand the number of job
government jobs open to
non-professionals that is to say
partisans if the size scope and
responsibility of bureaucracies are
curtailed by the economizing and
homesteading privatization policies i
just mentioned
a critical mass of political
appointments would then enact
meaningful changes in other policies of
those bureaucracies
changes legitimized by victories in
elections that is to say with contact
with the sovereign people for a change
not just going off on your own and
regulating as you please
this would have the additional benefit
of making political participation much
more broadly appealing
than it has become real jobs and real
policies would once again be at stake
every four years
to those who would worry that this would
bring back it would bring a return
to the corruption that bedeviled public
administration in the late 19th century
i ask first
what do you think we have now if not
corruption legal and illegal
second i remind you that the early civil
service reformers including the very
young theodore roosevelt had nothing to
do with the later
movement of progressivism that is their
ideas didn't teddy sure did but
the ideas didn't with its abandonment of
natural rights its elevation of the
science of administration above politics
those civil service reformers those
early guys were post
civil war lincoln men although of course
as we know roosevelt declined into
progressivism in his later years
finally uh the there's there's some
interesting things about foreign policy
that lincoln might say
because lincoln did have contact with
some foreign policy even though of
course he was preoccupied right with the
with the with the civil war and uh he
would recognize for one thing that our
that our
circumstances have been revolutionized
in the past 150 years
having witnessed the great world wars
the past century
he would understand how the worldwide
battle against far worse tyrannies than
his america ever saw
had made this revolution necessary
nonetheless we can cautiously derive a
few principles of foreign policy from
lincoln's positions
taken under very different circumstances
he described our condition in 1838
in his lyceum address one of his
earliest published addresses
shall we expect some transatlantic
military
giant to step the ocean and crush us
with a blow
never all the armies of europe
asia and africa combined with all the
treasure of the earth our zone accepted
to the in their military chest with a
bonaparte as a commander
could not by force take a drink from the
ohio river
or make a track on the blue ridge in a
trial of a thousand
years now allowing for a certain
pardonable exaggeration and all that
even in 1838
today we would not necessarily make so
sanguine a judgment
our geopolitical circumstances have
changed we're much more powerful
than we were then but also more exposed
because the world is simply smaller now
in terms of technology and so on
further because we are more powerful
we're now also
more targeted more often targeted by our
the enemies of our regime
lincoln addressed foreign policy at the
beginning and at the end of his national
political career
throughout his lifetime america's major
international
rival was great britain
which had yet to recover from the contra
tops of 1787 through 1813.
great britain had adopted a policy of
containment regarding the united states
which it regarded as an uncannily
large mirror of itself potentially a
large
giant island right with an already
extensive merchant fleet
and a growing manufacturing base we
today
face a policy of anti-americanism
against us
attempts to cut us down in the world as
a young
as a young a congressman in the late
1840s lincoln as you know opposed war in
mexico
he did so on two grounds one of them
largely irrelevant now but the other is
still very much alive
in 1843 the brits had entered into
negotiations
with the republic of texas on trade
this raised alarm bells the ever alert
calhoun put his nationalist mask
on once again as john tyler secretary of
state
he urged the annexation of texas which
would extend
slavery meanwhile free state democrats
argued for annexation on the grounds
that the brits might succeed in
containing american expansion
after the senate refused to go along the
whig party dumped tyler
ran clay in the 1844 election and as you
know the democrats nominated james k
polk a tennessee man as a compromise
between the northern and southern wings
of the party polk won
the senate reversed itself and ratified
the annexation treaty
some northern democrats now began to
suspect a pro-slavery conspiracy to
dominate their party
polk's subsequent war on mexico was
declared by congress
lincoln was one of only 14 congressmen
who voted against
declaring war suspecting the
expansionist
tendencies of the slaveholders but more
pertinently for our purposes considering
polk's order to advance the us army into
disputed territories
in an attempt obviously successful to
provoke the mexicans to engage
and therefore to induce congress to
declare war
we'll get them to attack us and then
we'll they'll have to declare whether
congress will have to declare
this strained the constitutional limits
of executive power making the president
into a sort of monarch in
in in lincoln's estimation accordingly
i think he would uh urge skepticism if
confronted with such events as for
example the sinking of the maine and the
fana harbor
uh the gulf of tonkin incident and
and and even maybe the war the the wmd
issue in iraq he wouldn't necessarily
not go in on one of these wars you can't
print out
but he'd be cautious about such claims
if he if he
heard them today he wouldn't want the
president boxing in congress
too readily he'd be he kicked the tires
pretty hard on any of those things
uh during the civil war um the british
policy again this is at the end of his
career
uh british policy again worried
americans in may of 1861
expecting the confederacy to win
independence
the british recognized the belligerency
of the confederacy a move that often
precedes
formal diplomatic recognition one of the
great accounts of this by the way is the
chapter in henry adams
education of henry adams both the tory
administration of lord palmerston and
the liberal party opposition leader
william gladstone
looked forward to seeking the permanent
division of the united states
despite britain's long-standing
opposition to slavery and
the slave trade british opposition to
the war
centered among those public figures
identified with the principled support
of liberty
richard cobden john stuart mill and most
impressively
john elliott cairns uh later called the
last of the classical economists
who wrote problem britain at any rate
who wrote
his book the slave power in 1862
all of these men identified the
confederacy as
an oligarchy as not a real republican
regime in effect taking the
position of the republican party that
that the republicans had held since
their
inception six or seven years earlier the
crisis came
in november of 1861 when the united
states naval vessel
halted a confederate ship enroute to
europe with two diplomats
james mason of virginia and john slidell
of louisiana who were heading for
britain and for france respectively the
confederates were interned
with french backing lord palmerston and
his cabinet issued an ultimatum
demanding the release of the diplomats
although the capture was just about the
only military triumph for the united
states government in that bleak year
lincoln wisely told his cabinet
one war at a time we don't want to get
into it with these guys
this is the most powerful navy in the
world among other things
he approved a message this is the part i
like he approved a message
drafted by his secretary of state
william h seward
saying that america was pleased to see
that the brits had finally adopted the
american position on the rights of
neutral shipping
which they had denied in the years prior
to the war of 1812
and with that with that elegant climb
down he uh he released the prisoners and
avoided war with with uh with the mighty
british empire
on foreign policy then lincoln exhibited
two statesmen like
characteristics knowing the necessity
but also the danger of executive power
most notably the president's powers of
as commander in chief of the armed
forces he reserved those powers the most
urgent occasions moreover he ranked
the threats his country faced he
concentrated his forces and his
attentions on the uppermost one
today for example he'd advise americans
i would guess
to consider which threats most seriously
threaten their security
do some triage right we've got all sorts
of enemies out there well which ones are
the top ones which one's the ones who
can really do us damage and which ones
can't
i would guess that he'd put china russia
and iran ahead of
afghanistan north korea and the
palestinian-israeli dispute
for example to put china russia and iran
first would mean to strengthen the navy
in the pacific and the waters near the
middle east
and to refocus nato on the defense of oh
central europe sort of what it was
intended to do in the first place
like all major american presidents
lincoln supported the right to
revolution or regime change for all
peoples
in his speech against the mexican war he
said any people anywhere
being inclined and having the power have
the right to rise up and
shake off the existing government and
form one that suits them better
this is a most valuable most sacred
right a right which we hope is to
liberate the world
close quote in finding ways to support
revolutions that vindicate the natural
rights of human beings
he would subject the revolutionaries to
the demanding
test of natural right he would also
subject himself
as in all else to the hard test of
prudence
so conclusion if you were with us today
lincoln would do four main things first
ask his fellow citizens to attend to the
regimes
and to polities in the united states and
the world
regime and polity these are the keys to
thinking clearly about politics
whether in 1776 1861
20 2011. second urge the expansion of
the realm of self-government in the
united states and in the world
politics not bureaucracy
third exemplify self-government by
offering
reasoned arguments for those policies he
endorsed
to do that politicians really need to
give themselves more time
to think they can have more time to
think
if they reduce the number of things that
government does and restore
important governing responsibilities to
counties and municipalities so that
elections and the politicking that
surrounds them
becomes important to ordinary people and
therefore worth
more of their time and attention finally
educate his fellow citizens respecting
the purposes and institutions of the
united states
and the statesman who employed those
institutions to advance those purposes
that is the sort of thing that david bob
and his colleagues are doing here
i'm grateful for him for uh to him for
inviting me
to join him in this enterprise today
thank you
i believe we have time for questions
i've been asked you
you we don't have a microphone to pass
around so i'll repeat your question as
best i can
that means you make them fairly short
because i as you can see i am an elderly
man
losing his hair and his teeth sans teeth
sands everything right as shakespeare
once said
so yes sir
democracy
okay um he the question is uh
lord acton's letter to lee um basically
saying that secession confirms democracy
rather than uh disaffirms it that it's
uh it's that that's he agreed with
southern secessionism
i think that lincoln's response to that
would be
very simple that you do have the right
to revolution
you certainly do have the right to see
session if
your opponent is like the british king
in 1776
or a napoleon at waterloo namely someone
who is out to violate the natural rights
of the citizens but once you're but but
it's not a constitutional right unless
of course
we're actually in the constitution so
the southerners if their
natural rights had been violated would
then have had every right to see seed
from the
from the from the union and lincoln
would have applauded them
they might have joined them i won't have
said illinois should join you
right but that wasn't what happened what
they were doing was
defending something that was against
natural right
namely slavery now of course there's a
whole discourse that i'm sure you know
and many of us know about
well whether is this true or not or is
there a natural racial hierarchy for
example which justifies
uh whites ruling blacks and and and
american indians and so on
that was part of race science right of
the 19th century
uh lincoln had nothing to do with that
though he didn't agree with that
and uh neither do i if you want my
opinion
yes
the question is uh what's the what's the
difference or what what
causes lincoln to start out affirming
uh his constitutional restrictions
uh the the the republic and the
republicans uh acknowledgement of
constitutional restrictions on
uh uh invading the slaves
invading the right to have slaves in the
in the slave states
right and he starts out there but then
in the middle of the war
toward the end of the war he emancipates
the slaves and
of course in the war the problem with
the war as as in any war and especially
in a civil war
is that you now have military necessity
involved
and so the the liberation of the slaves
which was a good thing by natural right
remember it's just that we can't touch
it constitutionally
once the war is is on then uh then you
then you get something
a different situation then you have it
as a military measure
and sure enough there was this
competition right between
lincoln who starts out saying okay we're
going to emancipate these slaves and get
them fighting against their masters
and davis and the southerners who are
finally dragged into the idea of well
maybe we should emancipate them and see
if they'll fight with us
the answer turned out to be that the
slaves voted with their feet for the
most part and joined the union army and
didn't really trust the confederates to
give them
emancipation at the end of the war the
second part of your question
i don't know my honest answer is i don't
know if you if you want to say something
about it go right ahead
oh yeah yeah that's right yeah this is
uh this is this is the dark now i know
what you mean the the
doctrine the doctrine that uh as a as a
war power if
if property can be confiscated in other
words if you're going through
and you're marching through a place and
uh
and the the uh opposing army is fed by
the fields that are nearby
you are entitled as an act of war to
confiscate those
uh the the the food in those fields
yeah that and and and he and this
gentleman is mentioning that
the the uh the uh uh the the
slaves free up of confederates for
fighting the war because then they can
leave um uh and that so that would all
be but that's part of what i mean by the
by the war powers basically as a
military necessity all of these
good things from lincoln's uh point of
view is
are are to be accrued from uh from
liberating the slaves yeah yeah
sounds like everybody wants to go to
lunch yeah
any other questions yes ma'am
oh what did my father do spoken
spoken like spoken like someone who's a
mother no doubt herself
right so um well my father was
a guy who was he'd been educated as an
attorney this is 1920
and he didn't like corporate law in new
york so he came back home to cliffwood
beach new jersey
which is on the it's not on the ocean
shore it's on the raritan bay shore
it's not far from new york and the state
of new jersey
decided to run a highway
i think it was today's route 35 down to
the shore
and so he and his partner bought up
hundreds and
thousands of acres along this area
and developed them with bungalows for
the people there's no air conditioning
in the 1920s right
so they put these bungalows along the
shore and they have this promotional
material
they had one sign that with a with a
girl in a bathing suit says
meet me at the jersey shore and uh
so so they they made a lot of money in
that real estate bubble of the 1920s
they lost a lot of it back in 1929 but
that's the way it goes
otherwise i wouldn't be here i'd be
sitting on a on a plantation somewhere
sipping mint juleps
hi guys
you